في ختامه القمه كما في بدئها ذكرت
هيروشيما ضيوفها بماساتها التاريخيه
حرصت المدينه على ان تري الزعماء الحاضرين
بعضا من شواهد ماضيها الاليم فلا مدينه
غيرها قتل من سكانها 70 الفا في لحظه
واحده بقنبله ذريه كوسي من اجل ذلك كان
تركيز اليابان كبيرا في القمه على عالم
خالي من السلاح النووي جيسون من خلال
البيان الذي ادلى به قاده مجموعه السبع
نعتقد اننا تمكنا من تمهيد السبيل لدفع
الجهود نحو عالم خال من الاسلحه النوويه
واكدنا الزخم الدولي لاحراز تقدم في نزع
سلاح النووي
بعد زياره متحف السلام يعود القاده
لمناقشه شؤون الحرب وهنا على خطاب الوعيد
على ما سواه
فرضت القمه عقوبات جديده على روسيا
واستضافت في خطوه غير معلنه من قبل الرئيس
الاوكرانيه
ومنحته وعدا لطالما انتظره لتدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين على طائرات اف 16
الامريكيه بدات توجه العام برمته ماضيا
على طريق التصعيد لكن لا مفاجاه بالنسبه
لكثيرين فمجموعه السبعين تعتبر حرب
اوكرانيا معركتها الخاصه
لا ارى مفاجاه فيما صدر عن مجموعه السبع
فقد انعقدت لتظهر دعم التحالف الغربي
الكامل لاوكرانيا
الصراع اشتد ايضا على واجهه اخرى فالصين
نالت نصيبها من الوعيد يقول بيان مجموعه
السابع ان بيجين تخلط الاقتصاد بالسياسه
وان سلوكها سيكون محطه مراقبه وهنا برز
مصطلحان جديدان على الساحه الدوليه في
العلاقه مع الصين الامن الاقتصادي
والاكراه الاقتصادي
[تصفيق]
خارج اروقه القمه واصل الغاضبون مسيرتهم
الاحتجاجيه معظمهم من اليساريين والحالمين
ومناهض الراسماليه الذين يرون في هذه
القمه تجمعا لاغنياء ومشعل حروب
وكما هي العاده لم يخلو الموقف من توتر
ومواجهات
عقوبات جديده ضد روسيا ودعم قوي لاوكرانيا
وتحذير الشديد اللهجه للصين تلك بعض من
خلاصات قمه مجموعه سبع الكبار فيروشيما
هكذا تعددت رسائل القمه لكن بدا ان
عنوانها واحد
التصعيد محمد البقالي الجزيره هيروشيما